how old were you when you started to
like are you like a child prodigy or
something i mean did you start writing
songs when you're like five or something
i started writing songs like about eight
or nine and then how soon before you
start to get famous like how old were
you when you were you know well that
took a long time because really i mean i
was kind of wild i started i learned how
to play piano learn how to read music
thought it was like school i quit i
forgot all that um it's pretty amazing
to make it as a musician it's the odds
are so slim you know it's really slim i
know i was i was cleaning up fish guts
with my hands for a living and then
suddenly could make
money off of you know not a lot of money
but but independent records touring song
t-shirts for your band and we made
enough we sound good what we were paying
ourselves 800 a month
for for like two years and that was
actually because we were on the road so
much that was fine did you take lessons
guitar lessons or you just figured it
out on your own no i just kind of
learned so i could write songs because
before soundgarden i was in maybe from
like 17 to 21 i was in about 10 bands
around seattle and they're all really
awful and all the songs were awful it
was usually based around a guy who wrote
the songs who was the singer
and there were bad songs and it was bad
singing and that's kind of why i ended
up doing it i was really a drummer then
was it hard for you to write with other
guys i mean you are one talent to do it
i mean every band you're in is always a
success it depends like an audio slave
no an audio slave i would have lyrical
ideas that would come to me or melodic
ideas and i would show them parts but it
was kind of one of those things where we
all wrote the songs together which which
is which is not a bad thing it's like
i'm in a room and and we're all just
sort of feeding off each other and each
of us is trying to push the song in some
direction that they think is great too
much democracy in a way in a way what
ends up coming out of it wouldn't happen
any other way so it's just a matter of
do you like doing it that way or not but
with black hole song specifically
in sound garden i just recorded it in my
basement it's like a bad recording i
played drums played all the instruments
but it's basically what was on the
record just a bad version of it me
playing it all and then give them the
tape and they literally can listen to it
and say
thumbs up thumbs down and that's kind of
where we were at was
if you like it we'll do it if you don't
we won't and what if they'd said to you
they didn't like it that would be enough
to make you leave a band i bet like you
say you know what what do you mean you
don't like this what are you guys the
judging jury no that's where something
like temple of the dog came from where i
was writing songs that i knew weren't
going to be songs that they would like
and uh ended up doing a side project and
that's kind of what side projects are
for sometimes did you write spoon man on
your own yeah spoon man that come to you
like this in your head bam and then you
wrote it down pretty much wow there's a
guy named artist
um the spoon man who's like a seattle
fixture
and he like he could walk in this room
with like his little satchel of spoons
and
and just captivate everyone here oh okay
he's really incredible oh so he must
have been honored when you wrote that
song yeah and he he appeared in the
video and and uh he was great in fact
that was one of the few videos where we
didn't have to be in it it was just
photos of us and then artists going off
and he's fantastic you didn't like the
video aspect of your career i don't
think because you even you even say that
was one of those videos where we didn't
have to be in spoon man which is great
yeah yeah you didn't want to be in that
the black hole sun video i think the
reason why it was so great was because
that was one where i didn't um have any
input and we had just done a bunch of
videos we did one for rusty cage we did
one for jesus christ pose from the from
the same record where
i was basically telling the directors
everything i wanted them to do and it
wasn't it was wasn't coming out good it
was i just didn't like the video so with
black old son i said just find the guy
with a great idea and let him do it and
let the filmmaker make the film i heard
for a while people you hear this every
once more like when bruce springsteen
used to make his videos they say oh
chris cornell's gonna be an actor did
you ever hear that for a while like they
were like
touting you as the next big guy and
acting i had um acting agents trying to
get me to commit to to like letting them
represent me if i decided right and
that's not your thing right they're like
we want to lock you down they use terms
like lock you down
we want to lock you up yeah
in case you decide
i think what they think is if you get a
you know someone sends you a script
whether you're a musician a milkman
whatever you are you're just going to
run and go yes put me in a movie yeah
because everybody wants to be in a movie
did you did you ever consider being a
movie did someone send you screen um i
got a lot of scripts and there's only
one
where i didn't i just said i don't know
anything about this and i don't want to
do it which was the usual suspects and
and uh you could have been in that i
could have been in that and i saw it
took me i saw it like three years later
after it came out and it took me
watching half of it before i even
realized it was the script that they had
sent me